So, now let's look at what methods
we can come up that actually makes
our future detection invariant to scale.
Let's take the same examples
of these two shapes.
Again, you can tell that they
are the same, just scaled up.
And of course,
I kind of look at this window.
It basically says that this is an edge.
Of course, when I look at this window,
it comes across as a corner.
So one thing I can do now is start
looking at different regions.
So, basically,
consider this region a circle, and
they start looking at different
sizes around the same point.
So, in essence,
what I'm doing now is I'm zooming out.
I'm kind of wanting to look at
the same region but from farther away,
which actually would start making
this object start smaller.
So I try out another region, a circle.
Well no, that doesn't work.
Let me try out, at the same point,
another larger one.
And if I keep going and let's say I
get to this scale, all of a sudden,
this detector is going to
fire this to be a point.
That's a corner, just like this.
So in essence,
by scaling up my detector regions,
I can actually accomplish exactly
what this one is doing and in essence
what that comes out to is now I would
actually have scaling variant matching.
So, in this basic idea here is the
region of corresponding sizes will look
the same in both images, as long
as I can come up with that scale.
So this does require a little bit of,
kind of coming up with the process that
let's me find the right size of the new
region that would let me
compare this scale to this one.